good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump
day we have a late show oh no tuesday
it's tuesday and good afternoon
millennials oh my god
you guys today we are so disoriented so
many things
only tuesday but it's also like one
o'clock because we delayed the show in
order to watch
olivia jade on red table talk and so
like so many things are happening first
of all
this is brighter in here the sun is at
like a different position than it
normally is so where like
our light might go in and out of
darkness and light just bear with us
and honestly that's a metaphor for life
yes it really is a metaphor for life the
truckers for tasha are outside and
they're just like demanding to be spoken
to
they're construction workers for tasha
maybe they're it's construction workers
for claudia
oh yeah construction for clubs they're
really excited about the new book
yeah speaking of thank you for bringing
that up i haven't brought it up in a
while so i just felt like it was
appropriate to talk about my book which
is coming out january 26
2021 it's called girl with new job the
crazy beautiful life of an instagram
thirst monster
it's pretty much everything of the sort
i started to now hand out copies to some
friends of mine
um and they're really just like giving
me such positive feedback so if you want
a fabulous book that'll make you laugh
it's not too long it's light it's a
little dark you know
check it out growthnojob.com
book girl with no job dot com slash book
audio electric
not election electric audio ebook and
hardcover versions are all available
um for pre-order and i would really
appreciate the pre-order great well we
have such an interesting show for you
today like so much
is going on that's why we had to delay
we also each watched some interesting
content yesterday
yes i watched the flight attendant and i
watched godmothered on disney plus it's
a new movie starring um
the girl who ran a marathon oh britney
runs a marathon and
jillian bell and isla fisher and it was
adorable and it was also made
like even better by the fact that bruno
sweets came to bed with me and like he
was like literally under the covers with
me for the first time ever
he was being so sweet he was being so
tired because he spent the evening
with theo two cousins being so cute and
they wore themselves out so it was just
like actually an amazing night
they were just like humping each other
with a great movie and a great man by my
side
so i've had a good night and a great
morning like doing the show a little
later i got so much done did a load of
laundry
took sweets out like three times it was
just so exciting
no same i literally had a full day
before we even
showed up today i had the exterminator
come it was just very busy and i feel
like i look more beautiful at 12 than i
do at like 9 30 when i usually start
i completely agree that i too feel like
i look more beautiful
my my face is more settled into itself
do you know what i mean yes and you lose
that like morning puffiness
yeah and just like that morning like
disheveled
skin cell look do you know what i mean i
do know what you mean okay i'm so glad i
think i do know about the disheveled
skin cells
so in our tv recap we'll talk about the
things that we watched yeah i mean
that's all
you guys should watch a movie it's like
a plus great movie you would love it
adorable
really funny too and i don't want to
spoil anything so head on over to disney
plus and watch it
okay so i guess i'll just talk about the
flight attendant while i'm here yeah
it's just briefly like two teams
um it's starring kaylee cuoco which
she's just so ingrained in me as the
girl from big bang like i just don't
feel like she can really play other
characters and she did a good job but
it's just like a really low budget
version of the undoing like they're
really trying to recreate the magic and
there are quirky parts of it
but the first episode is like basically
she's this fabulous flight attendant
she's like this party girl and she's
like traveling around the world doing
first class like meeting hot guys in
first class
and i want to watch that show like not
what happens after the murder and it's a
mystery like
where's the flight attendant before the
murder like yeah she was fabulous and
like yes she was definitely an alcoholic
but
it was funny like i wanted to watch that
so i don't know if i would really
recommend it i'm just like in it now so
like i might as well finish it and like
find out who killed the cutie but
it sounds like right yeah because people
are talking about it but i also just
want to say justice for hillary kelly
kiyoko because
kelly cuoco because she's not haley
kyoko kylie cuoco
they're very similar names that's
another coincidence haley i never put it
together hayley kyoko and
kaylee cuoco yeah that's weird
well she was in the wedding ringer which
is an amazing movie
and she's so good in it yeah that is
justice for her on that
you know it's like it's kind of what
happened like with the
the friends cast none of them really
were ever
in anything like super memorable after
that because you're just rachel green
you know yeah i feel it's a blessing and
a curse it's like you made so much money
you don't need to work again and it's
good because you can
you know totally well speaking of
friends
i know i was just going to say a
follow-up from yesterday's story when we
were like
railing on matthew um harry and his
rogue merch line
it's not rogue and all the proceeds are
going to covet release
i think the designs are still a little
rogue yeah no i i stand by what i said
on the design but
it is a legitimate thing and all the
proceeds are going to cover relief i
didn't think it was weird that he was
coming out with merch when he literally
makes like
from syndication and licensing like
millions of dollars a year without
leaving his bed so it's all going to a
very worthy cause and i think the
confusion stem from the story
was about the fact that he his new
fiance was modeling his merch and i
think it's the first time he like posted
her on his instagram so
the charity aspect got overshadowed and
maybe it was at the bottom of the
article but i didn't see it so
apologies we apologize justice for him
and his charitable endeavors and we
appreciate that
your delight is insane yeah well if
you're listening as a podcast you can't
tell but if you're watching on youtube
sorry we're super blown out we're just
not used to that midday glow no we're
not you seven day ghosts if we ever had
dreams
of doing the show at one o'clock then we
know that we can't no i think we're
maybe more of a four o'clock
group of gals i totally agree um
so is there anything else you want to
talk about no and i think like because
of the
like the light is like this for a reason
and the reason is the fast five stories
that we need to get into
so without further ado here are the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of maybe you're like your afternoon
crumb cake
i would love a crumb cake right now
right a little dry though because then
you wouldn't be able to talk no but i
would need a crumb cake
oh by the way there is an interesting
update in my life
so you know me i love a mcdonald's
fountain soda love love love
but recently during cope it's something
weird has been happening on uber eats
with all of the local mcdonald's they're
not
using their fountain machines it says
bottled soda and like i literally don't
need to order bottled soda it's so
disgusting
so i have journeyed into other options
and one of those options is chick-fil-a
there's one right by me and they have
crushed ice and i have to say
i do believe diet coke from chick-fil-a
is better than mcdonald's
wow have you been ordering any of the
food no why don't you get
a because i don't know there's something
about chick-fil-a that like i just don't
need in my life do you know what i mean
like
i love you have enough vices you know i
have enough like fast food that i really
enjoy and like
just to learn a whole new menu is just
not something i'm ready
i feel like if it's the menu for you
because it's
chick no it's like chicken based i know
and you're chicken base
no i know but it's just like it's really
not a new york thing
you stick to a chicken-based diet for
sure some people do plant-based i'm
chicken-based
it's just not a new york thing i feel
like people in like certain parts of the
country like wake up and go get their
chick-fil-a no but like they brought it
to new york because it's now a new york
thing
yeah i guess but it's it's really not
it's someone who's lived here it's not a
new york thing
okay well the construction for claudia
workers are saying
they want my attention they want to see
my titties they're just excited they're
construction for chick-fil-a
oh sorry i was in the middle of saying
something today's episode is brought to
you by axon taser
protecting our family is our number one
priority but we want to do it safely
and the people at taser believe that
safer self-defense is better
self-defense
their line of non-lethal self-protection
devices are small and lightweight
that you can carry them with you or in
your glove compartment or your purse and
they're powerful enough to incapacitate
an attacker
guns carry unnecessary risks for you and
those around you and even pepper spray
can harm you
as much as an attacker taser products
are off
are safer and easier to use you know
we are living in crazy times and if
you're not protecting yourself
you gotta be you never know what's
around the corner if you're jogging late
at night you're in a gas station you're
in a park like
no more putting your keys between your
fingers like protect yourself properly
their tasers use an electrical charge to
immobilize attackers for up to 30
seconds
allowing you time to escape and send
emergency dispatch to your gps location
so not only do they take care of the
attacker but they'll send an emergency
just dispatch using your gps location
all their devices come loaded with
features like laser assisted targeting
emergency dispatch
which will send response team to your
gps location upon firing more than 237
000 lives have been saved with the taser
network of devices
apps and personnel now you can own a
taser that's the number one choice of
law enforcement agencies protect
yourself and your family with taser's
line of smart
self-defense products taser is available
without a permit in most u.s
states get the taser pulse plus or taser
strike light
at taser.com with promo code toast save
fifteen percent now at taser.com
t-a-s-e-r
dot com the promo code is toast
restrictions apply seasight for details
taser.com promo code toast great
okay are you ready for our first story
the reason for this afternoon
post season yes i have a lot to say
olivia j
gianouli breaks her silence on the
college admissions scandal she says
quote
we messed up in her first interview
since news of the controversy broke last
year the 21 year old influencer sat down
for tuesday's episode
of jada pinkett smith's facebook watch
show red table talk
where she opened up about her parents
laurie laughlin and massimo julia
newley's sentencing
she said they are well they are both
currently serving time in prison after
pleading guilty in may
lori admitted to one count of conspiracy
to commit wire and mail fraud and her
husband pleaded guilty to one count of
conspiracy to commit wire and mail fraud
and one count of honest services wire
and mail fraud
mail fraud olivia started on the show
saying quote it's been hard i think for
anybody no matter what the situation is
you don't want to see your parents go to
prison but also i think it's necessary
for us to move on
and move forward so let's just start at
the beginning because
obviously i think everyone's been
waiting to hear from olivia jaden we
knew that she couldn't say anything
while the
court was still in session and the trial
was still going on but now that it's
kind of behind them and her parents
are serving their time she has the
opportunity to speak out and i think her
choice to go on red table talk was
really interesting and
kind of the harder route because in
this scandal olivia and her family have
really become the face of like white
privilege
and financial privilege and i think that
at red table talk it's you know hosted
by three generations of black women they
use their show
to you know lift up other black voices
and and talk about issues in the black
community
and this isn't necessarily like what
like they're bailiwick you know and what
they
usually talk about yeah so i thought the
choice to go on there was
super interesting and i think having
three different people who appear to be
on complete polar opposite sides like
i thought willow was probably the most
sympathetic towards olivia jade
because i'm actually sure they know each
other like just from being like
celebrities
kids and i'm sure willow they have
similar friends and they just grew up
similarly not completely the same but
similarly
i thought that jada was kind of in the
middle like understanding like
how kind of silly it might be to have
olivia jade on the show but also like
just being a mom herself and like so
sympathetic
yes and i'm such a warm person a warm
person and someone who understands
the nuances of i don't want to say
cancel culture but just like being a
human being and making
mistakes yes and then you had jada's mom
adrian who was just completely on the
other side of willow just being like
what we've built this show like why are
we having this girl she's gonna be fine
and that's the sentiment of a lot of
people and i feel like they all really
represented like the way that
the way that different people feel about
this situation yeah so
i do think by the end of the interview
like she i thought she did a really good
job like
i think however you feel about it like i
don't think you could say that she was
like
it was scripted at all or she was being
disingenuous like i think the fact that
she admitted like when it first came out
like she couldn't understand why people
were upset at her and then like
now it's been like over a year yeah it's
been almost two years
because it was in like february march of
2019.
um yes i think that she obviously owned
up to the mistakes that her family made
i think she was also very
honest about how at the beginning she
didn't understand
that it was a mistake or how or why it
was and she was like why is everyone
getting so bent out of shape the bubble
that she
grew up in so i think that she was very
honest and
ultimately gave a good interview
yeah you know and didn't did it didn't
victimize herself
overwhelmingly so like talked about the
struggles that it's been for her and her
family but like
understanding completely the level of
privilege that she
has and how they all
messed up yeah i mean it's super hard
for her i can imagine to like have to
speak on behalf of her whole family and
i feel like she did a good job of like
really speaking for herself
while also being like but this is a
similar sentiment and i think that
a lot of the coverage around them has
been like does olivia hate her mom lori
like
i remember when it was all happening
there was like helicopters above their
house it's like olivia jade confronts
mom
like it's like are they divided is she
mad at her parents like does she hate
them for ruining her life
um and i feel like she did a good job of
like explaining how they've really gone
through this as a family
and they share similar sentiments like
not realizing that like
they went to extreme illegal and kind of
unethical lengths just to get their kids
into college yeah you know
yeah so i don't know i thought it was um
it was a little short i'm not gonna lie
really yeah 30 minutes yeah no i i
thought it was going to be longer
really i feel like i don't know what
more they could have i feel like there
were some questions that they could have
asked that weren't asked i also feel
like there were some cuts so
maybe things were taken out if it was
like verbose or unnecessary
but i feel like they got to the heart of
the issue i feel like people can really
see
how olivia feels about the situation and
that she's completely sorry
and yeah working on all of it
all of it and giving back to her
community and just like being a better
influence and role model yeah because i
think like part of the reason why i
think she fell so hard is because
certain people like are on the internet
and make it very clear like i'm not your
role model like they do crazy things
and i think that olivia jade like has a
super young impressionable audience and
like
without saying expressly like she was a
role model to a lot of people which is
why it made it like such a
bigger blow when everything came
crashing down but the other thing i
wanted to say is
and how i was a good indicator of like
how
i thought it was a good interview is
that there was a lot of uncomfortable
moments especially between
adrian jada's mom and olivia who kind of
came for her the hardest
and i think that olivia took it super
well and i
i mean i think it was a tough position
for also the three hosts to be in like
their audience i think i think they're
going to get a lot of [ __ ]
for having i think when they announced
it they got a lot of [ __ ] and i think
towards the end i think that the
interview was very favorable towards the
end
and i think they'll get a lot of [ __ ]
for it so i i just
i think a good indication that it was a
good interview was like when talking
about like
white privilege and just like racial
issues and social inequality like there
were uncomfortable moments for olivia
and i don't know i thought it was very
good i'm always when i report on things
like this i'm always sympathetic to the
person going through it
and that i know a lot of people don't
agree with that and people might have
their own opinions on that which is
great because we live in a free country
and everyone is entitled to their own
opinions but i thought it was a very
good interview and i thought she was
genuine
i thought it was a really great
interview every time that uh we
watch a red table talk i'm always
infinitely impressed with
with jada and and the just the way that
the whole show is and what their
goal is i agree i i just think there's
not enough programs like it
agreed and we were just talking about
all the other things that she could have
done
if you know like say you're olivia jade
like what media interview do you want to
give also she does have her own youtube
channel and her own platform yes
she could have done her own apology for
herself
yeah and just like not had to not have
to answer direct questions and
plan it out and i think that this path
that she chose i think
it was a really good decision for her
yeah and i think that the interview like
it wasn't just
fluff and her just saying the right
things i think that
she really had to answer for a lot of
the things and also she
was talking about you know those
comments that she made i think it was on
zack saying show where she was
um talking about how she just wanted to
go to college to party yeah and she's
like i don't really care about school
and she's like the fact that i can even
say that
and edit it and upload it like that just
proves how out of touch i was
yeah i don't know that to me that
sounded like the statement of someone
who like
i don't know that was from her own
videos i think yeah that just it seemed
like she
in the last almost two years like has
definitely grown up quite a bit yeah she
gets it
she gets it and i know a lot of people
are like how could you not get it before
like
and it's true and jada even said that
like we live in a time where it's like
everything is
all over the news and everyone's talking
about all these social issues like how
do you just exclude yourself and so
i feel like they really asked her like
tough questions and she had answers for
most of them and i just i
i agree with you i had the same
sentiment after the jordan woods
interview because of course after jordan
was like i'm a kylie
stan i'm a kardashian stan i'm like oh
my god jordan what sucks and i just feel
like they
do a really good job on that show of
just like lifting people up
while also acknowledging like the
elephant in the room like what's going
on
and i just think they could have been
like way harder on her and like really
like made her cry almost like they could
have because it's uncomfortable but i
feel like they were just
very gracious while also like you know
doing the work
and i just jada has this like energy
about her that it's like very maternal
like
she's this warm smile every question was
just like smile and they didn't like
when olivia was like saying things they
were like right right yes yes yes
i just felt like they were it was a i
thought it was a lovely uh
interview yeah i think it went i think
it went well for her
i look forward to hearing what everybody
else thinks we just watched it like we
finished 10 minutes ago so i haven't
really seen like what the general
consensus is
from the viewers but i'm sure the
toasters will let us know their thoughts
and if
what you guys thought i'm actually
really curious i am too yeah and to see
what happens next what she does next
with she still has you know over
millions of followers and
a big platform and now that she's
finally what she kept saying is you know
over the past two years she hasn't been
able to say that she's sorry that she
messed up and that
she like she was worried people thought
that her silence meant she didn't care
right and so now being able to
put take the first step towards putting
this behind her
i look forward to the rest of the steps
that she's going to take yeah me too
it'll be interesting to watch yes okay
next story is
just an interesting one i sent this to
you yesterday and um
i'm interested to hear your thoughts
mario lopez is a finger licking good
colonel sanders
in new recipe movie what the [ __ ] is
this
i was so confused at this movie poster
when you sent it to me
it's like a sponsored lifetime it's a
sponsored lifetime movie about a
sexy colonel sanders played by mario
lopez
i'm sorry but i think this is like my
favorite news yes
mario lopez obviously inked like a large
deal with lifetime because he just did
that analyn mccord one which i actually
heard was like pretty cute but like you
know obviously no hallmark
so this is the next installment in his
overarching deal with lifetime and
i just didn't see it coming and kfc is
paying the big bucks so
sprinkled in with 11 secret herbs and
spices
mario lopez is serving up a big bucket
of finger licking good lovin
as none other than kfc sounds like a
porn description
it's just the post being funny signature
spokesman colonel
sanders deep fried by forbidden flames
sizzlin hot and juicy lopez
quaffed with the colonel's unmistakable
silver comb over
and well groomed goatee steams up the
small screen as a saucy chef
with the hots for his evil albeit well
to do boss's daughter in lifetime's
original mini movie
a recipe for seduction i just don't
really understand
like how sponsored movies work
like are there commercial like i'm just
so confused i it's also a mini movie
so a short film oh god this is just
getting worse and worse
i'm not gonna lie like the poster of
mario lopez was like a silver slicked
comb over like it was so bizarre we're
gonna post it to our instagram i just
needed a little context because i feel
like
when i sent it to you like you did not
know what i was sending you no not at
all and then after you send it to me i
like saw people reporting on it like it
was normal and it's not like we need to
address the colonel in the room like
it's very weird someone tweeted
i don't like kfc lifetime movies or
mario lopez but together
magic no honestly like mario lopez i'm
sure he's getting paid
a lot of money because that's the only
like
logical reason why you would embarrass
yourself so badly
but how much money do you think he made
not enough not enough what are the
tweets lifetime is releasing
a horny kfc movie starring mario lopez's
colonel sanders i will never
recover we have to watch obviously
obviously and i'm really curious what
this new mini movie genre is
speaking of things we have to watch um
premiering this week on nbc is the
grinch starring matthew morrison
and i do think that i do have to like
just watch at least part of it just
as like the as the person who i feel
spreads the most gospel a
anti-anti-matthew mars in gospel i think
that you have to do your research in
order to confirm whether or not it still
stands
but but i did see that clip of him yes
oh it was so disgusting
it was bad i hate your couch
he's just so gross like i couldn't
understand if he was saying i hate your
couch or i
ate your couch but regardless i didn't
understand the point of the commercial
and it was
very very offensive yeah yeah i don't
know if i'll be able to
to watch definitely not but maybe who
knows you never know where you're
live so like you're also like weird
things happen when you're live
especially when you're matthew morrison
like you know there's just
the possibilities for what could happen
are endless and that's exciting okay so
you watch that let us know
and watch i'll be watching recipe for
seduction
i just who thought this was a good idea
i think it's a great idea i feel like
kfc actually like for as long as i've
like been alive like they actually
always have like funny commercials like
rob riggle playing the colonel like they
do a good job reba playing the colonel
this just seems like a huge mess i don't
know they they're always like
ahead of the curb like maybe mini movie
commercials of like sexy colonel sanders
are
the next who plays his love interest or
the she didn't get
top billing on the um on the poster
unfortunately
when you wear a band-aid on your finger
as i noticed you are who do you feel
like
juni cortez okay i'm just i'm glad we're
on the same page whatever you think
you just said it well because i'm moving
i have all these hand-related injuries
like my cuticles are so dry
nails are breaking off i broke off a
nail literally in the middle of my nail
and it was bleeding for days so like my
nails are just like these little
sad things but it's just a sign of a
good move i feel like there's
truly certain things that are like the
most painful
things in the world obviously like
giving birth i i think like getting
like kicked hard in the nuts like i
think that really hurts and what they
should add to this is like when you have
an acrylic nail or just even like a long
natural nail that that breaks no a cro
no no imagine your natural nail breaks
in the middle more than halfway down no
i'm hearing you but when you break an
acrylic nail it breaks your reel nail
too and it could literally break at the
base of your nail
it's crazy okay but like that's i feel
like the lesson from that would be okay
i won't get acrylic nails but these are
my natural nails i try and keep my nail
health really good and there's nothing i
don't know what to do to make them stop
breaking in the middle
and it's so painful what other things do
you think like our top build is like the
most painful i feel like kidney stones i
feel like when you bang your knee
at del frisco's
oh my god jackie and i literally went
had a meeting once in rockefeller center
we had lunch next door like before or
after
and it was so crowded because like it
was like the lunch rush at
nbc so like all the nbc stuff and we
like tried to get a table and jackie
you could tell the story wait no i don't
even think you were there this one
that's what makes it even sadder
i went to sit at the bar at del first
coast i don't know why i was meeting
maybe i was meeting you but you weren't
there yet
okay i was sitting at the bar and i go
to cross my leg you guys know i do it on
the show every day
and i hit the top of my kneecap on this
huge gold gilded like
brick of a bar and i've doubled over in
pain like literally wanting to cry but i
was alone i didn't know what to do
and it was so [ __ ] painful so yeah a
good knee bang
can really a good job yeah um
cool is that an awkward silence
no no nothing's awkward when you have
love book
no just an awkward segue you guys it's
the holiday season i've been getting so
many dms like what's the love book code
listen please love book is a
personalized gift
that helps people express feelings that
might be difficult to say out loud
most customers use a love book to
revisit their fondest memories or to
list the reasons why they love someone
love books are completely customizable
and people can use them however they
like
so if you it's you would think it's like
great it's a great gift for a kid in
your life but it's also a great gift
for someone who you've known for a long
time or someone who like doesn't really
like a material item won't do justice to
like how much you love them
you basically use the book to create
characters that look just like you
or the recipient with all the features
that make them unique you can even
choose
your favorite hairstyle or outfits like
you can get really specific in the
customizations
so they have the option to personalize
each page as much as you like but they
also have an express option that you can
create a complete book in just a few
minutes
love books are the perfect gift for any
occasion but especially for
anniversaries
birthdays and the holiday season like
christmas and hanukkah coming up
um visit lovebookonline.com
toast to recipes receive a special 20
discount only for our listeners
again that's slash lovebookonline.com
for that 20 discount perfect for the
holiday season get your orders in
and get that 20 discount at
lovebookonline.com
toast love it really a great gift idea
yeah
okay next story you know who's gonna be
getting lots of gifts this year
howard stern because he thanked a new
five-year deal with siriusxm
this is big news obviously as howard
stern stands like always excited to see
what he does next
but i do feel like there was some
question
question about what he would do next and
theory is that it could be something in
podcasting spotify it's not i mean
howard stern will host his popular radio
show on siriusxm for another five years
under a new contract deal the broad
cancer announced
on tuesday so first of all
part of me is like when is howard's turn
gonna stop he's been on radio for so
long he's
so rich and he's 66 like he might want
to retire soon
but i feel like and i actually read a
statement when he was talking about on
his show like how he's gonna be doing
five more years it's serious
he's like i mean and i work from home
now so i really have no excuse to like
not do radio which i thought was
funny um and when a few months ago when
we were talking about how his deal's
coming to an
end like will he go to spotify like
spotify is really investing
after reading his book that you told me
to read which is so good um
what's called howard stern comes again
um
it's so clear that like he has such a
passion for like
radio as a medium so i don't think he if
he did leave siriusxm like i do
think the company like there's i can't
think of any people who like
have that much influence on a company
like if howard stern were to leave like
i do think siriusxm would
in a year or two time like actually file
for bankruptcy
yeah well i mean he is inextricably
linked to siriusxm and i think that also
gives him so much like free range over
his show
yeah which he needs in order to be able
to do his show so it's very mutually
beneficial but
shares of sirius did rise 1.8 percent on
the news that he was resigning
right so yes he is a big part of series
but i also feel like sirius does have a
lot of business outside of him
but he's uh like yes but i i think like
howard i think in his book he said he
has 60 million like listeners like that
listen to him almost every day
and i i can't imagine that half of them
like wouldn't leave if howard left
like i know people who just only have
siriusxm like
for howard yeah so and what and what i'm
saying like in the book he's like so
passionate about radio not like
audio radio specifically that i don't
think he would like diss
the medium by leaving do you know
anything yeah and no it could be like
such a big change in a big move he said
i've been proven right about satellite
radio over and over again
with this contract renewal i can't wait
to see what else i'll be right about
that's so funny because i really don't
agree with him on satellite radio but
he's
he's proven it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy he's proven that it's right
wherever he goes will be successful
right so of course satellite's
successful because that's the medium
that you chose to love
yes but i do think satellite beyond
howard certain also beyond us because we
don't listen to radio we don't we don't
know if we're not in cars
yeah we don't have like commutes yeah so
yeah it doesn't apply to us that's true
i guess i'm just biased in like my
lifestyle not
i don't have a car so um but i just feel
like now like with like bluetooth like
what do you need a car
what do you need serious example i don't
know even when i'm in a car with
bluetooth like i'm always reluctant to
hook up my phone i just like want a
different experience i don't want to
like okay
you know something like you want if
those people on the radio didn't talk so
much i know
sometimes i would listen to the radio
like i want someone else to choose the
songs for me i don't want to listen to
the songs that i listened to while i got
ready that morning the am thumb radio
is so problematic in the sense like you
could be in the car for 30 minutes and
not hear one [ __ ] song no
it's so upsetting and like those shows
like war of the roses like what's up
where they
call people and praying call people oh
elvis saran in the z morning zone yeah
but like elvis is a personality and i
feel like it's akin to you know howard
or
us where people listen to hear about him
and i get memories of elvis jerry i'm
like literally like growing up
yes and so i understand like bobby bones
yes but all like those like
gamified like shows that are just like
take up time
is the breakfast club on satellite or is
it on
amphum anthem oh that's a good show yeah
okay but i'm sure you could also look at
it on demand and it's a podcast and well
that's like everything
though yeah but it's right this is part
of i heart radio which is ampham got it
got it got it yeah but like howard you
can watch on youtube
sometimes yeah
two minute clips not enough not enough
okay ready for our next story
yeah a little big news not for the first
time little big news
a little bit a little big town for the
first time since 1978
the kardashian family christmas party is
cancelled
have you seen this i saw chloe when i
saw the headline that said like
canceled for the first time since 1978 i
thought it was a joke
like yeah no i'm like what the
kardashians they weren't even born but
truly they've been having a christmas
eve party since 1978
and this is the first year they won't be
having one due to covid chloe
announced on twitter that the coveted
cases are getting out of control in
california so we decided that we're not
doing a christmas eve party this year
i mean obviously because we can't be
gathering in groups of like 30 or more
but
this is just devastating as a pop
culture stand and someone who really
studies the kardashians
you know religiously this is huge for us
yeah no this is a bummer like the
content is always so good
who's there who's not there what are the
girls wearing who's performing
who's having it where who's house yeah
so much and it's
it's gonna be missed for sure yeah and
it's like someone who's obviously never
been invited but always feels like they
should be invited i'm actually glad it's
not happening because like now i won't
have vomo
that's so true for you yeah every time
the kardashians get together i'm like
genuinely upset and offended that i'm
not invited when like in no possibility
like in no world would i ever be
yeah but it's like i just feel so close
to them you know yeah no i i do know so
i just hope that this means next year's
party will be two times bigger
better been getting like smaller almost
i feel like maybe five years ago they
were like such big ordeals with a huge
performance and everyone got like super
dressed up
and then when it was at courtney's it
was like kind of low-key and it's like
nobody knew where to do it and i feel
like they've been just getting
progressively smaller
except when kim had like a full backyard
full of snow but i feel like maybe now
this is like the kick in the ass they
needed for next year to make it like a
big extravaganza as well i wonder where
they would have had it this year i feel
like they should have
kylie's new house her backyard she was
posting like on her stories yesterday
like her sunset
and it literally looks like a las vegas
pool club like all the like chairs and
cats like yeah and like
yeah yeah that's true um i don't know i
feel like kylie doesn't could wouldn't
host it
if kylie hosted would be a totally
different kind of party with like
literally tick-tockers and youtubers
yeah it's actually crazy how like d like
kylie's like
in so many ways she's like so old she's
like so accomplished she has a baby
but she's also like so young with her
tick tock you know no and that's the
magic of kylie jenner and she's also
keeping the family like
super young and relevant relevant but
then also courtney hangs out with
addison so it's all it's all weird
it's all mixed in there but speaking of
youtubers we were talking about
previously because we both watched
hannah mojo on call her daddy
i finished it yesterday it was so good i
did not know
like really anything about her and i
feel like my experience watching the
episode i was so
impressed with her and then i actually
started watching like her mtv show tana
turns 21. oh my god you did
like came up on my youtube search
suggested for next and then like i
started to get a better idea of who she
is like while i was watching the episode
of her on call her daddy like i didn't
know how old she was and i would have
assumed she was like
30 like until i heard that she like she
had a show where she just turned 21
which is so crazy yeah i have been
telling you about hannah for a while
because i thought i had to experience it
for myself i watched
like half of her interview with caller
daddy and it was not what i thought it
was going to be i think towards the end
which i didn't watch yet it's like a lot
of like
sex blow jobs which um is not what i
tuned in for i just like want to know
more about tana and i actually agreed
like i thought she was really smart and
the way she spoke about like
her many scandals and how like for so
long she just like tried so hard to make
people think she was like this type of
person
and like she's only recently been able
to like give that up and just be like
whatever like think about me what you
want
and also the way that she grew up like
in like a really broken home and
i didn't realize like all the friends
she hangs out with on her instagram
stories like amari like they're from
las vegas together yes so i just learned
a lot about her i thought it was a very
good interview
yeah and she was talking about like her
many scandals and so i googled like
because i didn't i really didn't know
that much about her and then i realized
tanacon
yes and then i was like oh yeah so then
i had to
learn what tanacon was about it was
while i was watching 10 and turns 21.
like it was all in like the aftermath of
tanacon
oh it was but watching the show like
made me um
sort of annoyed because i hate watching
like people who are just like these huge
stars who like surround themselves like
with man like her manager i don't know
if they were just like putting on for
the show but it was like he's on our
manager anymore and there's like a lot
of people wondering why
good jordan right jordan was like not
here for their dynamic like interesting
like he was just like
he was he wasn't being a manager he was
being like a friend and also like a
hater
and that was just not the support that
she needed i love that she's friends
with her friends
from las vegas las vegas because i'm
sure like that grounds her a lot
but i was just like not enjoying the
other people surrounding her
interesting and like having experience
like getting to know her first from call
her daddy i just feel like i have a
whole different
perception on her as if than if i like
knew about her from youtube and her
various scandals
and she also said on call her daddy that
like that
show was like a dark time like and it
was super like
stage like fake fights with you i mean
yeah she was like literally taking a
bath with mari like
what were they doing a face mask and i
was like i get what you mean it was yeah
it was like so just like
contrived yes totally okay fifth and
final story a little sports news wait is
it the fifth and final story that's
brought to you by better help
yes is there something interfering with
your happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely
online there is a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available to you
you can log into your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
there's never been a more pertinent time
to start therapy if you are not in
therapy and you've been thinking about
it
and seeing this how we like really can't
leave our homes nor should we be leaving
our homes and it's just easier to do
everything from your home
better help brings therapy to you you
can log into your account do
phone calls videos messages it's like
the easiest most 21st century
most easy way to do therapy
they're committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors
if needed at any time it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today
visit betterhelp.com toast that's better
h-e-l-p
and join the over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help
that they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states so the
special offer for the morning toaster
listeners to get
10 off your first month is
betterhelp.com
toast you have to use that link to get
the 10 off again it's better h-e-l-p
dot com slash toast i'm sorry to
interrupt you no worries it's just some
sports news that i think you'll find
interesting because news
some snooze breakdancing snood
break dancing will now be an event at
olympic games
starting in 2024. oh wow summer or
winter
um 2024. i think the whole olympics is
off now
yeah summer summer yes is it outdoor
is it outdoor breakdancing it's the
paris game so what did we just
we were supposed to have winter we were
supposed to have summer games in 2020
so summer games in 2024 summer so are
they
summer summer summer summer i
so are they moving summer from 20 to 24
just skipping the summer one
they are moving this year i think to
2021 i think
okay i'm still not clear so confusing
but at least people will be breaking
seeing their idea that's very exciting
breakdancing their way through the
confusion
in an attempt an attempt to attract a
younger audience the international
olympic committee
said that the new flexibility is part of
reforms of the olympic agenda 2020 and
added that the decision
will help make the olympic games paris
2024
fit for our post corona world oh i guess
because it's like a solo sport
oh because i'm not seeing how i hope
that by 2024
if they wanted to appeal to younger
people they should have like fastest
typing or something so they should have
like best teams may just be like dancing
mavis beacon mavis speaking she would
win oh yeah like fastest um
thumb twiddling yeah no but like best
like tic tac dancers like
charlie could represent the usa i mean
she does represent the usa
um and mighty well might add so like
that's pretty cool for all the
breakdancers out there like
you're now an olympian could be yeah no
i mean i don't know if you know this
about me but when i was a child i use
people to break downs
and i'm too bad for it now because like
the position i have to bend down into
and like swing my leg around like my
belly just gets in the way
which is really unfortunate because i
really feel like i had a really big
talent for it
but i'll get over it and i will survive
and i will thrive but i won't be at the
olympics
got it well the construction workers for
claude are excited about
you know yes god break dance that [ __ ] i
mean i could try maybe i'll try it after
i'm just like not in the physical shape
or honestly the mental shape to be
getting down that low to the ground and
swinging my leg around
but like i'm sure there's a home video
of me somewhere do you know that move
i'm talking about obviously it's like
you're squatted and you do it for us no
no
you're squatted and like one leg is out
and your hands are on the floor and then
you whip the leg around
i can't envision it i'm gonna need you
to do it are you serious
okay move your legs i might like get off
camera so hold on
hold on
[Laughter]
you know what i'm talking about oh my
god is that an olympian
did that look familiar at all too from
our childhood yes
not gonna lie like my arm 100 just
popped out of the socket like i'm into
so much pain right now
thank you though for showing everyone
you're welcome and i just i was worried
that people wouldn't know what move i
was talking about you know
and honestly i don't have my
breakdancing shoes on and a carpet is
really not like the best place i need
more of like a smooth like marble
surface
um so that's why i couldn't land it but
i probably could if i tried really hard
maybe i'll try it out no you
i know that you could i've seen it
before you know you've seen it yeah like
sweet okay back in the day my shoulder
um is hurting me
so much literally need to go to the
hospital like
i i've never um probably just did it all
on the floor
big time i've never um like popped my
shoulder out of the socket what are they
dislocated did you pop and lock and jam
and break no i definitely dislocated my
shoulder martha
should be going to the olympics by the
way she's killing it on tick tock like
literally breakdancing her way
to millions of followers she could
represent the usa in the tic-tac
category or i would let her because you
know what she likes to pop and lock
and jam and break um okay my shoulder
hurts i think we have to wrap this up
yeah i have like it's two o'clock now no
i know it's like time for bed
no yeah no i'm going to live method
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast life
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher or public radio
i have ready to catch box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning shows leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow back at regular
time goodbye
you